Film Courage: J. F. Lawton had been
writing screenplays and trying to break
into Hollywood for years do you think that
would have happened if he hadn't met you?
Gary W. Goldstein, Producer/Writer/Author: My
belief is that J.F. Lawton was so profoundly
talented I see this in a number of people in
front of and behind the camera that eventually
I have hope and believe that he would have
made it but one of the things I would say
is at the time I was more manager than
producer when I met him lit manager and
you're right he had you know he was living
in a one-room studio apartment in the rampart
district of Hollywood back then a very let's
just say colorful if not dangerous experienced
on a day-to-day basis and he had dropped out of
film school and I'm not sure if I've shared this
before but he the way we met was I had bought
one of the early macintosh computers and a
screenwriter friend of mine was working on one but
you couldn't just plug them in and work on them
someone had to program them and I said how did you
make it work and they said hire Jonathan so I did
three weeks in my office full time around the
clock asking me every question about learning
everything that I did and me suggesting these
are the kinds of programs that I would need
and he was really brilliant and
really lovely but he was quiet
but I became fond of him over the three
weeks and in some conversation toward the
end I started asking him more questions and
I learned that he was earning his livelihood
in two ways one he was beta testing software and
writing up articles in these computer magazines
he was installing computer systems for
film a lot of entertainment companies
on the one hand and on the other
hand he was late at night editing
trailers for the b movies that came
out of canon pictures back in the day
well when I learned that I thought well so clearly
you have an interest in the entertainment space
and then I found he had gone to film school he let
let me know he had written seven scripts that were
sitting in a stack in the corner of his studio
apartment that not a single human had read his
father was a an author an academician a real a
man of letters so Jonathan came by it naturally
so to answer your question when we met
I read about several of his scripts
and I said you're really you're you're talented
rather than refer you to an agent I want to work
with you but these scripts are as good as they
are and as much as they evidence your talent
they're a little bit quirky and what I would
like to have as a means of introducing you in
a meaningful way to the community because we all
live in a steady diet of hope and expectation that
we're going to discover the next great voice
the next great project the next great artist
that's a critical energy and so I wanted to
be able to frame him in a certain way and
have a certain quality of screenplay and so I
asked him I said I want to work with you but
it's not a condition but I would really like it
if you would create on spec a new screenplay and
I would like that screenplay optimally to be a
romance I don't care if it's a comedy or drama
and the reason I chose that is because when you
learn about someone's personal story you can zero
in on things and in his instance he was 23 at the
time quite young and he had been in a relationship
he met a young lady when he was 18 and they'd
been in a five-year relationship and he was
still madly in love with her as she had just
left the relationship to say that he was
sad would be an understatement and not to be
masochistic but honestly I thought who would
write a better romance at this particular moment
than this young man so I asked him to give me a
romance and I said just a classic two-hander good
male good female rule no exploding bridges nothing
expensive like if I needed to make this very
inexpensively independently we could do that
and that's so he went away and he came back and it
wasn't long I don't remember I would say two and a
half months with the first draft of what was then
called Three Thousand the script that eventually
got transformed into pretty woman from drama to
comedy and without question it was the single
most refined first draft I think I've ever
had held in my hand it was really compelling
and I knew as soon as and I decided
it was so good I wasn't there
I gave no notes and I started to introduce it very
selectively and the feedback was so consistently
to say enthusiastic would be in there people were
wowed so I knew we had the calling card we had the
the welcome mat to introduce him
to the to the larger community
so I think given given his talent he would
have gotten there I think I gave it a nudge
and and that was my sort of specialty was knowing
how to present and introduce someone new to the
business so together I think we we accelerated the
process what a wonderful story what year was this
I'm going to say it was right
around 1984. oh wow okay I believe
interesting wow so you saw in him this sort of
reserved maybe genius but just needed some nudging
and you wanted to see several scripts of his
correct before you actually made a commitment
he reminds me that what I actually said to
him was let me read one of your scripts and
if I like it I'll help you find an agent which
was a very genuine comment on my part I would
would have been happy to do so well as it turns
out I read one and then I said this is really
interesting do you have another and he
gave me another I ended up reading three
unbeknownst to me he was being very I would say
intentional because he was giving me these scripts
in the order in which he'd written them so they
kept getting better and by the third I said you
know Jonathan let's you and I collaborate i'd
like to represent you i'd like to work with you
and he was delighted and that was the
end of the conversation other than
you know what next so yeah we we we had an
extraordinary rapport and I would say that he
people bandy about the word genius quite casually
I would say he was he was quite he he was what
would be my definition of a creative genius
and then and then of course the next project
that he wrote on spec was a result
of a lunch that we had together
and the more I dug into finding out who he was
and what his life experience was his family life
and all of that I learned that he had been he had
done he'd been in the military I've never been in
the military so to me that's a very alluring
world it's sort of a fascinating world to me
and Jonathan had served in the
coast guard reserve and he did that
he was in active service at the time that the
olympics were about to come to los angeles which
was many many years ago I have no idea what year
that was probably the very early 80s I would think
and I started to ask him about what was that tell
me what what did you do what where did you serve
were you on him I called it
a boat it was a ship right
and he he just sort of regaled me with these
stories of what it was you know and they had
received counter-terrorist training because of
the olympics so they had a very intensive program
and the more he talked the more I leaned in I
was absolutely riveted by it at which point at
the end of the lunch I said Jonathan I needed I
need you would you be willing to write a story
set in that world and that was the story
that was the foundation for under siege
and that's where he learned his i.t skills
was was in in the coast guard did they did
they introduced pardon me I don't I don't know
if that's a true statement I really don't okay
yeah fascinating and did you see where
he would write his scripts in this little
apartment off rampart I saw his apartment and
he was on the ground floor the front corner of
the building with windows facing on the alley he
was right on in on the alleyway oh wow and the
visual tapestry on a day-to-day basis was um
I don't want to characterize I don't want
to judge it but it was a constant parade
of police and working girls and drug dealers
and pimps and homeless etc and it was because
of the part of town he was in that was it that
was just the way it was on a persistent basis
so as a backdrop to the original script that was
Three Thousand it was like almost like the perfect
input right it was because the original was you
know everyone say oh it was very dark well it was
it it was darker and it was edgy but you know
it's not like people died and you know it was
but it but it it refl I believe it did reflect
the world he was actually living in at the time
fascinating very fascinating thinking back without
J.F. Lawton how would you attribute your success
had you not met him had it not been the right
time how do you see your career being different
well I'm eternally grateful for having met him
and we did accomplish a great deal and and not
everything that we did of course got produced
as is the case for everybody but I was really
fortunate I came without filters I came from San
Francisco from being a criminal defense lawyer
I had a burning desire to be in the film and
storytelling business the visual storytelling
business but I didn't have the knowledge to
back it up I didn't have mentors I didn't
know anyone in l.a when I moved here so I was sort
of like this blank slate just a big white canvas
and so my my mission was to befriend and
just chat up anybody and everybody and make
as far as I'm concerned the world I wanted
everyone in the world to be my five-minute mentor
and then I started you know I made the decision to
open a literary shang hang a shingle as a literary
manager and rented the offices got the furniture
and got the assistant got all the the attributes
of it and I remember sitting one day looking at
the phone on my desk with my feet up on the desk
staring at the phone for hours and it never once
rang and I thought oh I've forgotten something
I don't have a plan and I don't have a network
and I got busy and one of the things that was
at the top of the totem as a priority was I
need I need to find great people as clients
that said I was so new that I wasn't sure I
would recognize what you know other than we're
all great judges as humans of a good story but
in terms of the structure and how it's crafted
and all of that I was still learning but I
thought okay I'm gonna I'm gonna use the my
best sense to figure it out but at the same time
it's really important to me that I find people
that I find very attractive as souls
as as artists as you know like there's
a there's something really wonderfully
unique about them and I was fortunate
to sign his clients I didn't actually sign in
fairness that's not true I never had agreements
my you know my philosophy was very
simple I had to earn my keep every day
I would work hard every day representing someone
in in an effort to launch make their dream a
reality and on their side of the bargain they had
to work with every bit as hard not just writing
but making themselves known as best they
could creating their own relationships
right on a parallel track and I did sign
I did so I keep saying sign but I didn't
so it was a handshake any time
they were dissatisfied they were
welcome to leave but I had a lot of very long many
year enduring relationships and it turns out that
several of them Jonathan was not the
only great success story there were
quite a few you know Alison Burnett's done his
written been produced 15 times he's produced
a few of those he's directed several of those
you know Matt Reeves and his then writing partner
gosh they had minimal resume they had some
but Matt's going on to direct you know
and produce and write were for the planet of the
apes he did the one before that I forget the name
of that franchise or that episode he's doing
the next the batman that's coming out next year
so there's a number of these
people that started out with me
that were really quite you know they were
wonderful people and they were truly gifted not
all of them but quite a number of them went on to
have what I would call meaningful enduring careers
what was the original version of pretty woman the
original version was titled Three Thousand spelled
out which was the number of dollars that Edward
pays Vivian for her companionship for the week
it was a drama it was not a picture where boy
and girl end up together and in in in some ways
it was a much more realistic story and I think
it was very reflective of the writers sort of
the world that he lived in and the way
he was feeling about things at the time
but there was something undeniably
here's what I would say about it Jonathan
when he was in film school he kept writing
these very complex really interesting
leading women characters and I remember one
of our early conversations before we started
working together he let on that one of his
professors presumably a male as I recall
wagged his finger at him and basically said
you know leave that alone let the women write
women characters you focus on blah blah which
was like waving a red flag in front of a bull
john one of the things i'd say that we shared
in common was a certain reverence for women
and that showed up in all of his scripts no
matter how fl and they were all flawed but they
were absolutely magnificent and one of the things
I would say about his character his women elite
lead lead women characters was that they were
inevitably the moral superior in every given
any given story and I would say that was one of
the things that really stood out for me in this
sort of grittier world of Hollywood or the
collision of these two worlds the investment
banker from new york and the girl from the streets
of Hollywood coming together this unlikely duo
where he had a certain wound a certain
skepticism a certain you know agenda based
on his relationship with his dad and his life
experience his current girlfriend and then she
despite her circumstances was this ineffable
spirit who had this sort of moral code
she was just a delightful character who's
making the best of her circumstances
and there was something so alluring to me
about her in this original script 3000.
so while it didn't end well I just saw that
the relationship and who she was was such an
unexpected construction and I so I I I figure
I'm like a really good audience I'm like
I am almost like the perfect
audience to read a script
I don't read it when I get a script I
never read it as if I'm the producer
I try not to read it as up on the director or the
financier or the distributor or any of those hats
the closest thing I would say is I try
to read it as if I'm going to be the
lead actor but more importantly I try
to read it as if I am the audience
because that's ultimately who I am right and
that script was was I I a must-see story for me
so my belief in it was a thousand percent it was
like it wouldn't matter how many no's I heard
that was going to be I was going to do anything
possible to get that film made and originally
it was intended to be made as as scripted as a
lower budgeted you know several million dollar
independent film because it was set in just a
room in a hotel right we we didn't have a lot
of production value to worry about but the I guess
the the authenticity of both the lead characters
was so undeniable it was written
like he knew these people deeply
and then the supporting cast Jonathan had
a gift as well there's no such thing as a
secondary character they may be supporting they
may not have a lot of dialogue or page count
but no one in that story is not important so the
hotel manager even the elevator opera you know
even before it became a comedy you could see
these we were witnessing with and through the
eyes of these people and they were so
interesting on their in their own right
so it was I don't know if that answers your
question but it was absolutely a mesmerizing read
how obsessed were you with the screenplay
when you first read it I wish I could take
it back to the moment I closed the script
cover because I was I it was a script that I
know that if I can't stop reading which I
didn't I read it cover to cover in one sitting
which is not that extraordinary but but it's
a good sign but I know when I closed the
screen cover I was speechless like I had just
experienced something probably the most special
script at that young juncture of my career that
i'd read to date and I could see it it's it's
there's something about a brilliant screenplay
that draws you and it takes you on a journey
that is so detailed and and emotive where
the characters are so different or unexpected
that you feel yourself literally
being pulled into the story
and that was the case with three thousand it
was certainly I was I was devastated at the end
but apart from the being devastated
because of the reality of the story
and the experience of the characters
when I closed that script cover
I was a bit stunned into silence like I know
I have a movie I for the first time you know
I this is like I want this to be a movie I produce
that's the first time I said that to myself and um
i I don't really you know honestly it's almost
like you go blank after that and I don't remember
all the particular conversations that we had but
I know I immediately reached out to Jonathan and
said I am so happy we're working together this is
this is a special script scripts are fascinating
creatures and sometimes there's something that
really stands out it might be a particular
character it might be the world it might be the
descriptions it could be dialogue it could there
was something about Three Thousand where the whole
of it was just right and all of it drew me in
what was interesting was when I finished reading
it I was so excited and yet I was also very
pragmatic I realized I was still relatively new
in the business I mean certainly I hadn't produced
except for a couple of micro budget little you
know but I hadn't produced anything the world knew
and Jonathan was still relatively unknown
he was not yet an established name
but what I held in my hand merited a lot of
attention and the question was how do I get
from here to there how do I create that energy and
the one thing that occurred to me was I think this
is such an artful compelling beautifully crafted
story that it lives at the level of the early like
extremely rarefied atmosphere that
was sundance institute so I called up
I had befriended michelle satter who was you know
sat at the right hand of robert redford since day
one building the institute building the festival
and all of all that it had become and they had all
these beautiful labs and workshops and they had
one called the production lab where they would
pick I don't know a limited number eight ten
perhaps projects and invite them once a year
it was maybe a week-long event and you would
go to utah and you would workshop the project
meaning you would have a level talent show up
all these resource people would show it for free
editors cinematographers actors you name
it and so you would take that script and
break it down and you'd start videotaping scenes
with these actors and sort of trying to you know
find what's working how to improve it
etc so I sent it to michelle and she
quite quickly called me back and said I want this
project I want you I want to invite you guys to
come as the writer producer so we did and
it was one of those exalted moments that
you'll never forget because when you're still
relatively you know you're you're at the lower
end of the ladder you're climbing the ladder and
then you're invited to sundance already amazing
but beyond that one day I remember I could
I see the scene I'm sitting there and there
are actors and there are the video cameras and
Jonathan's there and a bunch of other people
and we have these wonderful
actors playing edward and vivian
and we shot a scene and suddenly I hear a
voice whispering notes in my ear what if and
I look just like I thought I was dreaming this
man that was whispering in my ear was paul hirsch
editor of star wars editor of you know an
oscar winning you know like 50 of the greatest
films ever and he is offering me creative
notes it was like I died and gone to heaven
it was a magical experience to see this sort
of come to life in that venue and of course
Hollywood took notice that was the whole idea well
one of the inciting ideas was I want people to I
want this in the trades I want people to see
that by association this is a quality project
and that and it worked the phone started
ringing people were very interested it
started to have this sort of create this
this cause celeb this buzz this energy um
the script had a consistent it's been taught
in film schools it had that sort of consistent
response it was one of those rare scripts
that sort of hits everybody where they live
everyone can relate to the humanity of this
story and so we were very blessed that way and
that you know obviously like every film it travels
a very twisted journey and it goes off the cliff
here and it dies by a thousand paper cuts over
there and and so on but you stay with it and
I don't know if I've ever shared the I sent it
wide option to best run and then I got it back out
and then I optioned it to new regency and we were
still stalled we couldn't get it financed or cast
Richard had Richard Gary turned the project down
and during that time back when I was at best run
I had friends mark and scott who produced mystic
pizza which is just such a brilliant film and
when the lights came up of this little friends
and family screening to get feedback before they
locked picture I had I had no criticism to offer
but I saw this girl on the screen and I said I
don't know who she is but will you introduce me
and that was Julia Roberts and they did they
were very kind and Julia and her then manager
read it and was attached for three years
before we actually went into production
but unexpectedly because Hollywood is nothing
if not non-linear right it's full of surprise
so I sent it to someone I had
known when he was a junior
a lesser executive somewhere and then
he became a senior vp at touchstone
and I sent it as a writing sample saying this
is not disney material it's about a prostitute
but you're going to absolutely flip you're
going to fall in love with the craft this
writer is someone you need to know and we're
going to come in a week hence you'll read it
we'll come in next week and we will pitch you
a couple of more disney appropriate stories
and it was only several days before the phone
rang and and the call was we want to buy it
and I was taken a little back I said gosh
we talking about the same script well we were
and I mean there's a there's a lesson in this for
everyone in this business like you cannot know
what's happening behind the curtain you don't
know all the forces or influences that are
at play disney touchstone in this case had a
the wonderful project what about bob and it was
going in depression with Gary marshall directing
and diane critten and casting in the full laura
siskin line producing and they had the full team
and at that time michael keaton was the lead actor
well the deal went awry I don't know the details
but the deal went awry so production was sidelined
and they thought gosh we have Gary we have this
team assembled and they looked at our script and
thought great we'll create a marriage so there
was this meeting a week later that was no longer
a pitch meeting it was about we want to buy this
script and we just want to know can you lighten it
the question actually from the president of the
studio was on the disney lightning scale this is
a foreign we'd like it to be a seven can you do
that and I answered absolutely yes we can do that
because it was pretty evident
what they were asking and
as a result we not only inherited I mean I
I'm not so brilliant that I would have thought
of Gary marshall directing this particular film
and we were fortunate because i'd never had a
big studio a major director and a deep pocket
so I went back to Richard gere's agent ed
lamato and said please because ed loved
the project would you go back to Richard
now and the studio backed it and they made
him the sort of the godfather offer that you
couldn't refuse and so Richard finally said yes
and the beauty of that was they've been
auditioning and meeting and screen testing
many many many actors both for the male and female
lead and you know it's it's there's sort of a lot
of it's it's public information there's you know
the long list of name actors and actresses who who
who sort of paraded through and fortunately many
of them declined either passed on it or whatever
for whatever reason it didn't happen but Julia was
not on their radar she was like an unknown actress
at the time she had shot steel
magnolias but it hadn't come out
and she was so you know mystic pete's a
wonderful movie but she was not yet sort of
well known to either the public or or the studios
but now with Richard if you have your anchor
tenant right then it was like okay now this
is possible just maybe I just wanted them
to screen test together that would
have been all my dream right and so
I you know I lobbied and said you know this is
but it had to be Gary marshall and the idea was
Gary meet her alone just the two of you and
you're going to fall in love and that happened
so when Gary marshall versus Gary goldstein says
to the sea suite of Hollywood of a major studio
this is my girl I want to screen test it happened
and once they did it was it it was so undeniable
so the journey of a film is so unknowable so
unpredictable and that we ended up with our
dreamcast and it turns out a dream director
I didn't know what was even in my dream
is it's you know it's the stuff that you can't you
can't make up just happens so Three Thousand was
initially in a kind of a one-room scenario maybe a
hotel room it was in a hotel very simple locations
you know it's all a little bit of a jumble if I
had to go back and parse what was this piece there
or that piece there but fundamentally the the bulk
of the the bulk of the original story took place
in a very limited environment you know there was a
car there was a street that was a hotel it was not
extravagant and so once it went to the one
producer or the the head of the studios they
said can you lighten it up on a disney scale
this is a four we need a seven and so then you
added these side characters and maybe well the
characters most of the characters were there
there was the hotel manager there was kit the best
friend there was an elevator you know a lot of the
a lot of the infrastructure if you will was
there but it did get expanded there wasn't a
big party scene perhaps there wasn't you know
there were certain things that didn't exist
or that were dressed up shall we say
you know I don't I don't remember that we
had quite so showy a sequence on rodeo drive
that sort of thing so yeah it it it
definitely evolved the beautiful thing was
you know my my my job was clearly to discover
and and launch and protect great young writers
and I knew that when we were having
that conversation with disney
that it was really imperative so the only the only
condition I really had was not about story it was
really about protecting Jonathan and the condition
that we put on it was he has to be guaranteed the
first rewrite because I had such faith in him
that he would break the back of this and turn
it exactly into the proper you know the like
the best version of its comedic self knowing
the the and this isn't a negative it's just to be
expected the studio would bring in other writers
Jonathan had no never been produced he wasn't well
known and so he committed the first rewrite we
delivered the first rewrite and long before it was
delivered I was getting calls from agents saying
Gary you know they're reaching out to us for
our clients for you know potentially hiring
our clients for to do a rewrite and I said I know
it's okay thank you for letting me know but it's
absolutely you know to be expected and they did
there were three other writers who came in and the
first one I won't mention the name because I was
not a fan of the work at all it was unnecessarily
it was actually surprisingly dark
and I wasn't a fan of the writing
but they brought in another writer bob garland who
was from the electric horseman wonderful new york
based writer and he polished up all the business
dialogue that was sort of his mission and the
final writer barbara benedict who was a beloved
and you know very sought after script doctorate
came in and did the final rewrite and I would
describe her work as bringing it back as close as
possible to the rewrite Jonathan had delivered
to the studio sort of brought it full circle
yeah we were very we're very fortunate this the
you know the integrity of the script was in full
tact there was a fair amount of you know Gary
marshall is he had that gene that magical gene
of finding the heart of everything that he I
mean his legacy is so profound both in on the
big and small screen right he just had that gift
and so our our arrangement with him was yes we're
shifting this from a drama to a comedy but you
know we're doing it quickly and we're moving and
so once one take is scripted and then improv
and which was consistent with his style he gave
his amazing directory to watch you
learn a lot watching Gary marsha what
when I got to watch him work he gave enormous
freedom to everyone on the set not just the talent
he invited participation at every conceivable
level he gave actors the freedom to riff and
and and you know find the moment and you know
lean into it if you will so it was it was an
extraordinary the set was a really really
exciting place it was a small small budget
by studio standards we were way way down that
register and there was a lot of freedom because
a we had Gary marshall b we were such a small
budget they weren't paying the kind of attention
that they do to some of the bigger films but it
was a it was a truly wonderful time so that one
connection at the sundance lab kind of led to it
how did you how did it's forgive me I'm sorry her
name one more time michelle satter michelle satter
okay sorry about that how did you know michelle
i'm not sure how I originally met michelle it
might have been through some of her staff for
being at sundance I used to go every year to the
in the early years to the sundance film festival
so I don't really my memory doesn't stretch
back that far but michelle was someone that
as soon as I met her I just recognized this is a
wonderful person and really frightfully smart and
and and I've always been incredibly
grateful because you know in fairness
sundance did I don't think they really got the
proper public acknowledgement for the role that
they played in the evolutionary development
and the possibility of that particular film
interesting but it was but it was a key moment
certainly it brought it it brought it to the
forefront of people's attention what were
some of the lowest moments you faced trying
to get pretty woman made or 3 000 made whatever
evolution it was at oh gosh every film has its
peaks and valleys sometimes the valleys
outnumber the peaks or so it seems at the time
if I look back and think from the
time I held a first draft script
in my hand at the time we were actually
shooting a film it was only three years
and in the timeline of many films that's
not very long it's actually quite wonderful
but during that time there were moments when
it seemed you know when vestron declared they
were going into bankruptcy that was uh you know
there was a lot of strain because if the script
was if we didn't get a turnaround on it if we
didn't actually paper and buy out the script get
it back it would have been buried forever that's
what happens when you go into bankruptcy right it
gets locked up so there was a lot of I was I was
really concerned about the project at that point
that when we optioned it to new regency I wouldn't
say there was a low point there was a frustration
not anyone's fault but it's not always
easy to put films together and get them
on track toward production so it got
stalled and so that would be more frustr
frustrating over a sustained period of time than
it was upsetting or a low you know a low point
Richard I was so convinced that Richard was right
for this that when he said no to the project which
happened as I recall both at vestron and then when
we were for some reason I had this crazy idea that
when we're at new regency we should offer it
again new environment but his same reaction
and I understood it richard's a wonderful
you know super educated professional great
I mean he's fabulous but he is a sophisticated and
he has a a different taste you know being the guy
in a romantic comedy wasn't necessarily the high
point of his you know on his wish list it was
almost contrary to the things that
he was most attracted to edgy darker
more sophisticated projects
so there was no surprise there
the surprise was that he we we eventually
succeeded in getting him but I would say
another low point might have been when we first
were setting that we we set it up at disney
and I saw all of the people cycling
through perhaps the lowest point for me
I should have been the happiest
because I had a major studio I
had a major director I was like oh
my gosh we have succeeded and yet
i had a really strong inkling about what
this project wanted to become and the
casting that was necessary to get there
and to me the cast was Julia and Richard
and I didn't have to be 100 right about that but
but it's a sliding scale there's a sort of palette
of colors if you will and as I was watching all
these other actresses and actors come through
some of them were just meetings because they
were too big to audition they were just big names
there were meetings they were auditions some
were screen tests and as I watched some of these
meetings and auditions and certainly the
screen tests I felt my it was like my heart
hurt I had my heart set I just I trusted my
gut I've always trusted my gut on casting
and it's not that I'm right it's just a gut
I knew what the film could be with Richard and
Julia and if I couldn't have one or the other or
both we'd do the very next best thing but when I
saw some of these screen tests and auditions and
they were so the far side of dare I say the vision
that I had for or that Jonathan and I had for it
there were moments when I felt I was seeing
the premature death of my film of the film
and and I couldn't help but feel anxious and sad
and like we we've got to find a solution here
but again the god smiled we got our
dream cast and it all worked out
i think I think part of the lesson
there is you really have to know
when and how to speak to an issue and speak up
to the right people at the right time and really
try and influence the outcome
and then when the film hit theaters how
surprised or not surprised were you with the
crowd's reception well it's always a surprise you
know people always say did you know it was a hit
the answer is no of course not we were actually
our reputation when we were shooting was oh that
little film in trouble we were again a very small
batch by studio standards we were turning it from
a comedy from a drama to a comedy we were it was
known that Gary marshall god bless him was going
to be doing a lot of improv so it wasn't like
there was oh my gosh that film is going to be
amazing no we were like almost more like an
experiment than a film in many people's eyes
we did a number I forget the number we did a
few test screenings in outlying areas of la
and held focus groups afterward and with
each successive screen test the first one
or two were like okay okay that's good but
I'm nervous but as we got audience reaction
in what was working and what they loved about
it and we kept throwing more humor into it
the the reactions were you know you're standing
in the back of the theater a darken theater
and you've got a full theater and you're you're
you're just on pins and needles waiting to see
are they going to laugh in the right places
are they going to laugh in the wrong places are
they going to understand what's going on are they
what's the word of mouth as they exit the theater
and you're watching their body language literally
are they sitting up you know and the latter test
certainly by the last test screen but i'd
say the last couple of test screenings
the audience was you couldn't have asked for
a better reaction at that point I wouldn't say
oh my gosh we have a hit no we were hopeful we
were going to live because the patients are going
to live when it came out and did the business
that it did which was back then in 1990 march
of 1990 we came out and it did like 11 million
and changed the first weekend that was a wow
the fact that it went up a little bit like 12
million the second week that told us oh gosh
we have the best thing in the world going for
us word of mouth people love it and they're
talking about it and I don't remember precisely
but that film lived actively in theaters I was
it's at least half a year I think it was actually
slightly longer which of course would never happen
today even back then it was an anomaly to have a
an active theater presence for that duration but
I think even more surprising than that looking
back is it's over 30 years later 31 years later
and it's finding new generations of audience
around the globe it is a film that you it's like
a machine that just keeps churning out joy
right and so to be associated with something
like that is really quite phenomenal it's a
blessing and who could have guessed it that
were all of the reviews positive was there any
criticism of the film of the subject matter
I was I don't recall that there was any
negative there might have been but I can't
I can't recall that what I do remember was on
the eve of releasing that film the thing that had
I don't think I was alone in this there was
a certain nervousness about putting a film
out into the world where the role you know this
lead character is a working girl and she's young
when I met Julia she was 18 when
we shot the film she was 21 or so
and she was a very youthful energy right so
she was this here's this young beautiful girl
who's a working girl and as much as we tried to
paint the right version of that picture carefully
i was really concerned because it was a time of
great feminism the glorious steinems of the world
were you know on the front pages and I thought we
were going to get pilloried I thought there was a
good chance that there would be a lot of pushback
that people would be upset with us how dare you
and to my great surprise that never it never
came to be those very people that I was most
nervous about embraced it so I was actually even
more than the critics I was concerned about some
big public figures who were leading
the feminist movement at the time and
we might have stepped on you know we might
have hit the wrong chord here but again that
the thing that really un was underlying this
story I mean it's pygmalion it's cinderella it's a
it's eternal right it's a dreamscape
and it's a beautiful love story and
so much so that it that that I guess it over
rides whatever sort of socio-political instincts
of the moment might be present
but yeah no the embrace was
i I might have selective memory but
the embrace seemed fairly complete
if it had been released now let's
suppose have been made in 2020 2019
pre-pandemic do you think it
would have received the same
acclaim would there have been would there have
been people that had issue with certain things
that I think I think not yeah okay it's
very hard to say what might have been
in some ways I think the original story might
have been better received in the 2020s than
than the version we made but I don't know I
don't know I mean I think there's something
as I said I think there's something
predictably eternal about our love of
story and the way we react to story in certain
archetypes and certainly romance in general
so I don't know but I think I think that we live
in a time when people are certainly more critical
and that film might not have fared the same
is Hollywood a game Gary in a sense yes
I suppose but I think life in a way is a
game like it's in in the best sense but
you sort of have to understand the rules of
it people talk about breaking into Hollywood
which I always find fascinating because life is
not an event it's a process right and I think
when people think about you know people
people are very given to stories in their
craft and their dream of what it
is they want to accomplish we know
at show business but very few people really
think about the business side of the equation
and I find a lot of creatives in particular are
not intentionally random but they are they end up
being random in their approach focusing on craft
not thinking about how they're going to navigate
as if our industry is somehow
different from all other industries
which it's not I mean it it is in a sense but
it's not in the sense of being relationship based
and I you know what what I would encourage
people is I try and train people to be hyper
focused hyper intentional radically transparent
and not think about needing a representative so
much as being themselves a presence developing
rapport creating relationships in this business
and understanding that the first
thing they have to know is who are you
who are you in the world
what do you care about what
what's your creative dna what's your signature
what what are the kinds of stories you want to be
participating in or writing or directing
or producing whatever it might be
and then thinking about if that's true
who is it that I really need to know
if hypothetically if I could have a hundred
people over time be my champions and mentors
who would they be and that's going to be
different from me to the person sitting next to me
and then making that reality come to come to be
right I think a lot of a lot of people are taught
unfortunate habits so they learn they mimic habits
of of their peers which may or may not be optimal
writers may for example send upline query letters
that are deeply impersonal and fly into strangers
in boxes asking them to either produce it or
represent them or whatever it might be a big ask
as opposed to humanizing the process
over and again time and time
again I get the sense that people
people have a story that Hollywood is not
welcoming that it's that they have they
don't understand their value and they
don't know that the welcome mat is out
which couldn't be further from the truth if
you approach people the way you would in any
other environment so what I wish for people is
that they get more comfortable being vulnerable
and telling people what's unique about them
why who are they what's what's what's some
any one really delicious unexpected nugget from
their life experience that makes them memorable
tell people share with people what was why was
this particular of all the possible stories in the
universe why this one what's the connective tissue
why was that so important to you that you put
all your soul equity into creating this and
a third leg of this school very important is
don't just send it out randomly
if I want to send you this project
why you why have I chosen you not because your
name was in a directory I researched you there
was some one film that you made perhaps that was
like I got sucker punched in the third eye it's so
spot on or maybe it's your entire body of
work there's something that called me to
think you might be a right size fit a good
match for me and for this particular story
say those things pick up the phone don't rely on
social media don't rely on blind query letters
make it personal this is a personal business
reach out to someone and do not be a snob
you're not going to probably reach the name
on the door nor do you necessarily need to
I've always learned I built my entire career based
on one simple realization early on all I need to
do is befriend the assistant the assistant or of
any you know when assistants move on they go to
the next little notch up which is still entry
level it's a creative executive it's a director
production it's a you know head of
development whatever their titles
all of those people beginning with the person who
answers the phone which is usually an assistant
these are your target these are
the people who have enormous value
who are so aligned with you you have so
much in common with them they are highly
vetted they are usually like they beat out 50
people or more to get that particular perch
they're ambitious they're sitting on
the inside learning the business and
on a producer's desk or an agent's desk
or whatever it might be casting studio
and they are going to last in that position for 18
24 some number of months and they will matriculate
because they're really good and they've had to
work really hard and and you know that's their
sharpening stone these people need relationships
with you as much as you need one with them
and most people don't understand that it's
like the currency of most of us is who's
what relationships do I enjoy with talent in front
of the camera behind the camera it doesn't matter
do I know other good producers
writers cinematographers actors
whatever it might be casting directors
we're all in the business of relationship and so
it's a beautiful game of human failures and
everyone is instead of being narrow focused and
saying I'm just going to I'm not going to share
who I am as an artist as a creator as a writer I'm
going to put out a blind query letter with a log
line etc and I'll send it to a stranger who does
not yet know me and I'm going to hope and pray
to get a good response and the common refrain is
not a positive response I send out hundreds
I get two responses there usually passes
very typical as opposed to saying I'm going to
dare to be uncomfortable and awkward for a moment
I'm going to take a minor risk it's not
threatening my life but I'm going to take a minor
risk of being uncomfortable and I'll call someone
who does not know me and I'm going to introduce
myself and I'm not going to ask a big favor the
first couple of calls I'm only going to ask advice
it's gonna that's what I learned early on is like
make everyone your mentor ask advice keep the call
to three four minutes do it again a week later do
it again a week later make a friend and they're
as desirous of that as you are you just have
to catch them when they're not overwhelmed
so I think I think you know it's a funny
word is Hollywood a game and I think yeah
if you want to win at this if you really want to
have a viable sustainable career as a creative
what's interesting is the artist you all you
know everyone has more than one story one hopes
and the story may be brilliant but what makes
it really interesting is the point of view of
the creator and why they did it and what's
their life experience we we react to one
another we are attracted to that and even if
someone falls in love with one of your scripts
they're never going to go forward
with it and lessen until they meet you
the creator so I think I think in a sense
you know it's it's really having that sort of
divine inspiration that just comes down and
gives you the permission like oh my gosh I
don't need permission I can just reach out and
talk to whoever I want no one is unreachable
that was my earliest lesson no one is unreachable
if you're humble if you're vulnerable if you're
if if you make it pleasant you're you know and
you can say to someone oh my gosh I'm terrified
I'm so nervous to be calling you even to an
assistant because it's true as long as it's true
but the more you let yourself be known
and the more other focused you become
the more generous you are the more
you share and ask questions that are
like of human you know truly interesting
to humans it's it works magic
you win over an assistant and I know I'm
rambling on but if you went over an assistant
you went over everybody in that office
because they have the full trust of
everyone in that office they've been hired
relied on they're a critical part of the
of that mission if you want to win over an aw you
know a group of people get to know their assistant
so it is a game in some sense and to get
in the game you find that one assistant
person that's there before
everyone else maybe making coffee
getting it ready answering the phones
how do you do it in a way that's genuine
well the question is the answer by being
genuine and saying you know I when I was new
i would just turn to people and say I'm new
I'm the turnip that just fall off the truck but
I'm really committed to making it in this business
but I know how much I don't know I have
a couple of questions if you could spend
three minutes answering my questions it would
mean the world to me people can't resist the truth
if it's real if it's genuine when I would call
assistants of course you don't know who they are
it's just a person answering the phone and
I would just introduce myself and say look
this is and it's what I was talking about earlier
I'm an aspiring screenwriter or fill in the blank
I am absolutely mesmerized by the work your
company consistently puts out into the world
that's why I'm reaching out and yes
I have a project that's very much
that shares a lot of kinship with the
kinds of projects stories that you tell
but I'm not sending it to you I'm
not asking you to read my script
I just want to establish a relationship with
you and I get their name so that I can when
I'm off the call research them and find out
all sorts of delicious stuff about them online
and I will have a question or two and it's
usually something I know they can answer it
might be you know how do you operate as a
company are you you know I'm not going to
send you my script but are do you accept outside
material it could be were you there at the time
they made this last film that came out in march
that was just so phenomenal how did you get to
be there how did how did you get to work for this
extraordinary company and where do you want to go
I mean I know you don't want you know
you're you're paying dues you're sitting
in the crosshairs of this amazing opportunity
but where do you see yourself in a few years
you know where'd you go to
school did you go to film school
I'll ask any question that
comes up in the moment for me
but there will be questions to which I really
do want the answer it'll be it'll help inform
me about this person and I always build in and
say look you know I've used up my four minutes
you've been amazingly kind to take my call I
just want you to know I really appreciate it
and I have another question I'm thinking about
a couple of things but i'd like you know what
you're busy I'm you know I'm going to let you
go but I'm going to call you a week from today
if you have three or five minutes available that
would be absolutely extraordinary but thank you
I researched the heck out of them I called them
back the next week exactly when I said I would
and if they're available great and if they're
not I call back again my idea is that people are
very welcoming if that's your expectation
that's probably going to be the reality
if you welcome that it can be a very welcoming
experience I don't mind people sending me query
letters but I'll tell you there's universe galaxy
of difference between if someone sends me a query
letter and I've never spoken I have no idea
who they are and they're sending me a storyline
with the goal of me reading and possibly
producing it or whatever their intention is
versus someone who's reached out
to either me or someone on my team
making themselves known as a
human developing some rapport
taking the time investing a multiple of
calls over the course of a month let's say
and now they're really familiar with someone on my
team and that person and this happens all the time
whether it was as a manager or as a producer
someone would come to me and say you know I've
met so and so and they're really nice I think
they're really smart and I've just read some of
their work because you do that after three or
four calls now when the the welcome mat is out
would you take a look at
it my answer is always yes
that's that's my team member you know
and and and that's kind of the reality
now it might not be direct to me it might be
to my head of development or it might be some
but that's how you penetrate that's how you
get welcomed in a query letter after you've
spoken with a human that's addressed to the human
you spoke to is a totally different experience
than just a strange peach unexpected email
coming into my inbox or someone else you know
why why is it coming into my inbox and I that's
not to be that's not hubris it's just pragmatism
there are so many ways to play
the long game build rapport
with the faith that the long
game is actually the faster track
we often hear it's impossible to get a screenplay
read and especially now so many new writers want
to get in to Netflix want to get a meeting with
someone is it impossible no it's not impossible
but I think you have to calibrate you have to
be realistic I mean people talk about Netflix
a lot certainly it's the big line in the jungle
and we see a lot of good projects being produced
are required so that's great Netflix is actually
one of the companies being as big as they are
it's understandable they're a company who
basically advertises they have a policy that we
if we don't have an existing relationship
with you don't knock on our door
so it would seem logical that people would have
this feeling like oh I can't get read but there's
but it's but it's really not what it seems what
they're really saying is invest a little time
make yourself known to us how do you do that well
in the case of the first of all there's there's
there's a couple dozen very vibrant streamers not
just Netflix they're not the world of streaming
they're one of the biggest of and there's a lot of
places that you can go who don't have you know the
policy if we don't accept unsolicited material
or you can't come pitch us whatever it might be
but if you really want to get in the door it
reminds me of you know back in the day when
carlos antenna wanted to play at fillmore west up
in San Francisco and bill graham the empresario
was like I don't know who this kid is and he you
know people you knock and you knock and you knock
it's like jeffrey kastenberg always used to say
if if you can't get in the front door go through
the back door if you get in the back door climb
through a window if you can't go in through the
basement there's a way in and that's true well
carlos santana climbed up a drainpipe on the
exterior of the building to the third floor and
fell through the window into bill graham's office
that's how they met well I don't recommend that
necessarily but it worked it started his career
by the same token if you want to get into Netflix
how hard is it to research who are all the people
who've either produced for them an original or
had a film acquired by them and cozy up to them
this is a team sport this is it takes a village
to get any project made serious feature limited
series docu-series whatever so you're going to
want to be knowing these people regardless well
why don't you just find the ones who are doing the
kinds of projects genre budget that are similar to
yours who happen to have that relationship and go
that route there's a lot of ways in but there's
the other and and the other way is there are a
lot of people who work at Netflix befriend them
it's not all this is not a like a pass fail report
card or menu of options it's a human reality
if you really are determined to get into Netflix
there are people at all levels from from assistant
all the way up where you can identify them and
you can find them on linkedin they're they're
named and you can reach out to them and you can
do what we were just talking about a moment ago
which is introduce yourself but not to say I want
a pitch meeting or I want you to read my script
I just want to get to know you because what
happens is if you actually invest a couple of
short calls doing that over a period of weeks that
prohibition against we don't deal with strangers
or we don't read unsolicited material vanishes
it evaporates because now you're not unknown
that's a human metric and you can overcome
that now I'll share a quick story about
many many years ago I always when I have a
project I always put together what I call
a top 100 list who are the people that
ideally in every category that I want to
that I would want to approach to talk about
this project from editors and writers and
cinematographers and casting directors to
producers to buyers studios streamers you name it
and I will just go through
that list and prioritize them
and I'll reach out to them and usually again it
may not be the name on the door or maybe it is
but the idea the story that I want to
share is that years ago I made a list
and it wasn't arrogance it was just I'm it
was a dream so I added a name to my list
that was the most preeminent name in Hollywood at
the time and probably still is Steven Spielberg
so here I am a little guppy and I put
the name of Steven Spielberg on my list
and I think you know you know normally you would
think oh sober up child it's not gonna happen
but as it turns out I had gotten to know this
wonderful guy young guy named mitch who was an
entry-level guy I met him when he was an assistant
he got promoted to creative executive and he was
now a creative executive at amlin his ultimate
boss was stephen and so I spent some months just
nurturing that relationship and one day someone
sent me a script and it was absolutely gorgeous it
was beautifully crafted a story young characters
kind of a very special care very emotional
young young leads but it was
just tremendously well done
so I called up this fellow whose
name was mitch and I said mitch
I read this script we'd been co-conspirators we're
both starting out in the business we were friends
now new friendship and we were excited so he read
it and he called me back he read it on the weekend
the usual monday morning call back and he he
called me back he said he praised it he said
this is absolutely gorgeous it was very emotional
it took me back to when I was that age I had a
not dissimilar experience fabulous thank you it
was really really interesting it's going to be a
pass and I said okay mitch I one favor why why
is this a pass you just you were just singing
at spratuses and it's because it's too small for
steven I said okay that's fair I understand that
but let me ask you a question if you put this
script in steven's briefcase for his weekend read
and he were to come back monday and say to you
this is a pass would you have any and specifically
whether it's because it's too small or otherwise
would you have any cause for embarrassment
would it in any way jeopardize your standing
in the company they said no it's a brilliant
script I said great then I am on we're on a
phone you can't see me but I'm on one knee and
I am begging you put it in steven's briefcase and
he did steven read it and he wanted to buy it now
no one was more stunned than I was but I think
this is a business that turns on belief it's a
business that turns on passion it's a business
that you just got to go with your instincts and
get your head out of the game sometimes because
this is the fear factor right this is the
don't take risk factor speak the truth
and make friends of people if I can get stephen
spielberg to want to buy a script I mean he didn't
Gary goldstein's name I might as well have been
the clerk at the local convenience store right
if an agent by the way had sent
that very same script on my behalf
it would have been absolutely a pass
it would never have gotten to Stephen
because it wasn't about report wasn't about an
exploration it was like okay it's a pass I get it
magic happens when you make yourself available
when you make yourself known when you care enough
to ask the right questions to speak your truth
the fact that I as a young guppy in the business
could get the attention of Steven Spielberg
and maybe actually have a project together was
unthinkable people would have said you're nuts
so do I think that it's hard to get your
script read I think it's hard to get your
script read when you don't take risk if you're
relying on the wrong mindset the wrong strategy
a blind query letter or
relying on some third party
we all of us need we deserve to get in
the game we deserve to have relationships
to have cohorts and collaborators and champions
and fans and allies and help one another mutually
at what point is too much though I think many
people in the entertainment industry they're
long on enthusiasm but sometimes certain times
it can be too much maybe they gotta sort of reel
it back in because you don't want to hurt your
reputation where oh it's that person again that
happens often and and it may be a very well
intended enthusiasm sure but the enthusiasm I
think you're referring to is a very self-facing
enthusiasm okay so it's it's it's it's maybe
not intended to be overly grand or braggadocio
or any of that but it may come across that way
or just too self-focused period right so what
I would share with people is is that idea that
vulnerability and honesty and truth is not
a push energy it's a pull energy it's a
very attractive energy but don't spend the
whole time talking about yourself in fact
one of the great life lessons in not just
Hollywood but in life is fewer words listen
more the less you say the fewer words you use to
communicate the more the other person remembers
if you talk too much this just becomes a blur
but be other focused care about the
other person be curious I think that
curiosity and gratitude and all you know
they're by words today but they're real
those are real energies and if I approach you and
I'm grateful for you know thank you so much for
taking this call not over being overly solicitous
but just honest and asking about you know how
you know how long have you been there and
how did you get that job it's awesome and
where do you aspire to go I would probably be the
only person not only that day but that week month
and possibly longer who's actually shown a genuine
curiosity or interest in you because everyone else
is in a rush to get past you to the boss it's
easy to make friends in this business actually
but
you're right you can't assault people with
enthusiasm and expect it to be an effective
strategy it has to be very moderated less is more
quiet is better than loud truth is better than
grandiosity so it's just being measured because
it's it's it's it's hard to you know the g-force
of people's enthusiasm can be unwelcome if you
were starting from zero today how long do you
think it would take you to get into a place like
Netflix to pitch ideas it's a great question i
i think it takes I think it takes a while
it's going to take a while regardless
you have to be committed you have
to be willing to invest some time
in the olden days we networked in
a different way we showed up in
person for coffee breakfast lunch
dinner office meetings non-stop
the advantage of I mean the downside to that
was it was extraordinarily time consuming
the upside of that was it was very personal
the advantage of today is we can reach anyone
we want I can google anybody find out how to get
in touch with them where they are where they work
if I don't know someone at that agency or
that streamer I can find out who works there
i can reach out to them very quickly digitally
I can speak to them on a phone I can get them
on a zoom I can do whatever you know those
are those options are very available to us
so we can truncate the time but we need more
frequency of interaction because of the lack of
personal connection if we're not sitting across a
lunch table from them it's different but again I
really think that's incumbent on us to be so
conscious and present and aware of what our
mission is and how we want to get
there I think the problem today is
we are separated by technology or we're connected
by technology but we're not physically in the room
with them more often than not people are saying
do I need to be in la no you don't need to be
in la if you're in la you'd be having the same
number of meetings that you're having right now
initially for the foreseeable so technology's
our friend but it's not as personal
the hardest part back then was finding someone and
getting together physically with them so you could
have a relationship with them today you can find
identify someone quickly in an instant online and
you can reach out to them instantly by email by
phone what have you but you have to invest in that
and make it personal you have to come across in
a different way if you're if the if the intention
is I just want a pitch meeting that's going
to be hard especially at a place like Netflix
until you build your those bridges those
rapport-based bridges that let you walk into
that opportunity so I think it's really less about
how is it the same or how is it different than
are we are we ready willing and able to invest
ourselves in bridge building human bridge building
or are we just looking for someone to set us
up for a meeting one is realistic one is not
years ago an actor friend of mine I ran into
him and he was he wasn't in a good mood he was
he was upset with himself and
I said what's going on and
he told me he'd just been to an
audition and he didn't get the gig
and I said what was it tell me about the role tell
me the project who was in the room blah blah blah
so he tell he fills in all the details and
it turns out it was the casting director the
casting associate the the producer I think the
director was I'm not 100 sure but there was at
least one producer there anyway it was a project
he really wanted these were really good people but
he didn't get it and he left and that was it he
was in a total funk that's that's interesting so
why are you so hard on yourself and he was like
what are you talking about I didn't get the gig
I said well look I we may I'm not an actor so
what do I know but I have this crazy idea that
the I the purpose of an audition is primarily to
get invited back that to get the gig is secondary
like look who you just told me was in the room
these are like people people dream about meeting
these people and you just spent time with them
and so I again it may be naive but I think
if you walk in and you're smiling and you greet
the assistant and you greet everyone in the room
and of course you're going to give your very
finest performance but you let them know you
as a personality and you make it fun and you
thank them and you greet them on the way out
there's a million reasons why you might
be might not be correct for that role
but they'll remember you and the job is to just
get invited back because if you're on the spectrum
if no is over here and yes is over here
these twins that were never separated at
birth right they're essential to each other
if you're on the spectrum and and you're
invited back you're inching toward your goal
eventually they're going to hire you it's a
given that's my belief that's my experience so
if if you know like people always says how do
you handle rejection I celebrate it it's like
I'm in the game I'm doing something right and it's
it's an opportunity and that was you know I did
a ted talk about it no it's just a conversation
starter it's I really believe that it's like when
someone says like in the mitch story if someone
says no to me this is going to be a pass it's
like fabulous I totally upend their expectation
instead of like and making them uncomfortable
my attitude is great that's fantastic the only
thing that would be better is if you tell me why
like I want to learn and what's happening is
yes you're learning but what you've also done
is you've bonded more deeply like that's a
human experience that is not common you're
gracious you're curious you're thankful and you're
open that's the person people want to work with
when you were actively reading screenplays how
hard was it for you to find a great screenplay um
it it's always a challenge
it's funny I just had um
i just had lunch on the weekend with an executive
producer a very popular tv series and he reminds
me that we met back in like he was quoting
me from 1989 like who remembers that far back
and the thing he one of the one of the things he
remembered was me saying you know I feel lucky if
one out of a hundred gets me really excited and
I think that's you know I don't know if that's
mathematically true but it seems like that's the
case and it's not because it's not always because
the quality is not there or you know or it's
not always about the caliber of the writing it's
oftentimes because for example me as a consumer
and as a producer I'm probably not the right guy
to write you know or to produce a a big sci-fi
movie or certain other kinds of affair there
are certain kinds of interactions or stories
that really appeal to me and many that don't
but I'm always writing to see how talented someone
is like how what what kind of storyteller are they
but yeah I would say personally I'm i'm not I've
never been a volume producer I've always been
pretty fussy but I would say if I find one out
of a hundred that's worth having a conversation
to see if there's a there there if we get along
if we agree about the vision for the project if
it's something we want to roll up our sleeves
on together it's probably about one percent
and that was going to be my
next question do you think that
we often hear that 99 of screenplays written
are horrible what's your experience oh gosh
that's really hard to say 99
of screenplay is written and
that's a big pool usually by the time I you know
there's there's there's sort of a natural
evolution so I'm really not taking scripts
off the internet or I'm not posting on public
forums saying send me your scripts so I don't
know what the big the bigger ocean of opportunity
looks like I usually get scripts sent to me
through people who are either writers that I know
their representatives their attorney their friend
someone in the business a producer another
producer might want to share something with me
horrible's a horrible word
certainly there are those that I read
where I go gosh this is way off the mark
there's I ca you know it's it's I really want to
root just like for a movie same for a screenplay I
am that guy who I'm rooting for the writer
I'm rooting for the story I want to love this
if I read something that's so poorly written
that I just can't get through the whole of it
that's as disappointing as it is you know like
okay so it's not for me that's fine but it's
disappointing I want that to be better I want that
person to be better to be a better at their craft
what do you think 99 of screenplays get wrong
wow great question I don't know if there's a
sort of that ubiquitous one thing that they all
get wrong I just think that one one of the things
writers I would like to see more writers have sort
of a more systematic reality check system inner
circle system so that at a given point in time if
they feel it's ready for prime time they really
have a trusted group of not friends and family
but seasoned people people in the business who
know their stuff and how to read a script and get
the feedback I always do that to this day I still
I know that we get so close our our face is
pressed up against the glass we've been working
on something for seven or twelve or whatever
number of rewrites and we lose perspective
and if I were to give it to you and four other
people and you all come back with one similar
comment I know that I have a real issue that
I've overlooked if all five of you come back
with criticisms but they're all different that's a
win it's like okay now I can pick and choose which
ones make sense which ones do in my gut I really
feel enhance the story I think so I think one
of the things is not not falling too in love or
feeling too precious about the material that you
create but really being open and willing to find
the you know and bold enough and brave enough to
find the very best version of the story and that
requires I hear a lot of writers talk about well
um I really don't want to change it that much you
know it's no this is you know that's be a painter
be a sculptor write a novel this is a medium
that's designed for collaboration and I think you
need to take that as an asset as a positive and
invite it because it's going to happen eventually
how many pages into a screenplay before
you know it's a bad screenplay not long
there are many and and I sort of agree if someone
doesn't grab me somehow in the first three pages
with the quality of their craft or
something that's surprising in a good way
that's that's what I'm hoping for someone really
putting a hook in my mouth but 10 pages in easily
15 pages and you you sort of see the caliber of
the writing that the the quality of the craft
it's it's it's not likely that the the actual
quality of the writing is going to shift on page
30 or 60. when you sat down to read three
thousand later to be called pretty woman
where were you I was in I owned a home in west
Hollywood it was this absolutely charming 1920s
bungalow style classic Hollywood bungalow right
all sunlight beautiful yard the whole thing and
I had a room that was just like my
reading room it was a small like sunroom
and yeah that's where I did most of
my reading at night on the weekend and
yeah I like to read at home as opposed to
say at the office so it was a friday night
and you I don't remember what day of the
week it might have been all I can tell you
is I was waiting with great anticipation I had
very high hopes because I was so admiring of
Jonathan and what i'd what I knew of him as a
person but certainly what i'd seen on the page
and the only question was could he really
sort of jump it up to that level of maturity
and I promise you the moment he delivered it
to me I probably at that moment wherever I was
turned off the phone if we had phones that turned
off whatever you know metaphorically and it was
like okay this is the most important thing I have
to do this week I'm gonna go home and read this
and so three pages in you're loving it five
pages in were you waiting for the other
shoe to drop where you had notes and you
thought this isn't or you no the thing about
no I don't go into it with that sort of lens I'm
not looking for what's wrong it's just not my way
when someone grabs me from the
beginning which he did when
it's not heavy-handed it's just right when that
happens and I'm engrossed and I'm invited into
this and I'm he's got me right until he stops
getting me I'm not operating from here right
and that was from cover to cover that was
my experience I never really intellectually
assessed the script that's why I was
so excited about it because if I didn't
I figure a lot of other people won't that they'll
have an experience somewhat similar to mine
where they're so engrossed in the characters
that the way it plays out in the dialogue and
and all those other supporting roles and and the
friendships and the tensions and whatnot that
they're going to swim through
the script the same way I did
and that's what I pray for it's like
that's that's the win any tips you can give
screenwriters that would immediately improve their
screenplays especially in those first few pages
I don't think there's any sage guidance that
I have other than to recognize what you just
said which is the opening of your script is
so important you really want to set the table
right up front invite people let let people know
what you're you're inviting them into I've seen
scripts that start out with like a page and a
half or two pages of single narrative description
not a good way to start a screenplay
to make us do that much work to get to
our characters or the action so I would
say you know really take absolute advantage
and you know we're in the entertainment business
entertain me starting from the first moment
but other than that I don't think I mean every
story is so uniquely different not just because of
the conventions of the various genres but just the
storytellers are different and the I can't I can't
think of it's really yeah never mind I'm rambling
it's it's just the recognition that you that you
bring up in your by way of your question what's
the dna of a writer people are so fascinating
I I don't know that I've ever met someone who
is not possessed of the most surprising story
in life experience and the only people who don't
know it is the person living that story they take
them you know people take themselves for granted
they tell a lesser version they have these sort of
they they they don't see themselves the way
I see them or the way you might see them
I think the dna of a writer is so deeply anchored
both in this life experience ancestrally
in every sense there's a wonderful quote
by Ben Kingsley and I can't remember
it precisely but it's something like
our work evolves and over time
it becomes less careful less anal
less conscious and more a
reflection of the truth of our soul
and I think that's really the journey of an artist
it's there but it needs to be freed it's
like carving the day of it or letting off
wine mature and it's like as we grow into what we
do and we relax into it and we have the confidence
that we don't have to we're not thinking from the
neck up so much we're finding the truth zone right
I think we spend much of our life mastering
something becoming really good at the craft
whatever that is whether it's a creative
pursuit or not but then in time you just
cross this sort of invisible threshold
where it just you start taking deeper cuts
you trust yourself that's when it gets really
interesting what's the difference between writing
as a hobby and writing as a career the difference
between a hobby and a career as a writer
it's a choice and sometimes that choice
is conscious and sometimes it's not
there may be someone who you know who who
is a hobbyist who's as serious and and devoted and
and possessed by the act of writing as anyone else
they may lack the commitment to do what
it takes to make a career out of it
and there are a lot of people who think it's a
career but they haven't you know like what's the
measure of a career well the measure of a career
would be superficially are you earning a living
doing it but would also be are you really getting
the appreciation acknowledgement are you forging
the relationships with the people who really
constitute that community in a meaningful way
or are you an outlier and not an
outlier but are you are you an outsider
who's really not knocking on those doors I think
there are so many brilliant stories that get lost
to us that are important because people don't
knock on the door because they're they're more
content in the safety of it being a hobby they may
not refer to it as the word hobby but not really
and I think there are a lot of artists who
need champions they need people they need
a sherpa they need a guide you know one of
my early heroes was max perkins and max was
a man of letters he was a brilliant
writer himself but he was also
most of his adulthood and the single best editor
in my view of the in the 20th century in america
and he was the father figure who discovered
and nurtured and launched careers
for faulkner and hemingway and ring lardner
and thomas wolf and just the list goes on um
and a lot of these creatives either would
have there are a lot of inside won't get
into the particular stories but they're they're
faulkner might easily have never come to Hollywood
he might never have had certain of his
books published had it not been for max
and the same probably is true in varying
degrees with certain of his other illustrious
so clients think it's sort of a you know
it's it's hard to adjudicate at what point people
have the constitution to really take it into their
own hands and say consciously I'm going to
be disciplined I'm going to find my way in
or I'm just going to be a soloist
and enjoy the act of writing
and there's a lot of gray in between those two
um I think the first thing is just to recognize
the phenomenal joy if that's your if that's true
for you right like for me I'm a natural writer
I'm not an author and I'm not a screenwriter I'm
a writer they're different I take enormous joy in
writing it's one of my happiest moments of the day
but I don't see that I'm a professional writer
I think my my my marketplace skills are better
I'm better as a producer I'm better as
a fire starter and a facilitator and an
organ orchestrator than being and I'm a very good
editor but I'm I don't think I'm a screenwriter so
it's kind of knowing yourself and how far you
want to push it and do you have the gumption
to do so if we were going to break down the
day of two screenwriters so one who is quote
waiting to be discovered versus one who as
you say leverages their entertainment career
what would those two days look like
gosh very different now they may have equal levels
of discipline or lack of discipline when it comes
to how and when and where they write I mean
some writers it's like they're early morning
writers or their nighttime writers or whatever
is their sort of biorhythm creatively right
and do they do that consistently and do
they block out a certain number of hours
and do they hang the same go on fishing sign
on the door so the family knows leave me alone
right so those are all one sort of one category of
of discipline and decision that a creative makes
one is self-response makes a decision to be
self-responsible like it would be great to have
an age but it's not essential I'm still going
to make it so I'm going to be intentional and
I'm going to allocate a certain amount of my brain
and my my heart and my consciousness and my time
to having a plan I'm going to build my own
plan I'm going to say I'm going to dedicate
anywhere from 30 minutes a day to an hour a
day to two hours a day on my career versus
the hours that I spend writing which is about my
craft I'm going to have a vision a plan long term
short term in the next month or you know every
month I want to make these kinds of measurable
steps forward I wanted this to happen in
six months this to happen in 12 months
and you may or may not hit those marks but the
intention the entrepreneurial sort of energy of
yeah there's this other rail this other track that
I'm gonna pay attention to and and and respect as
much as I respect the greater amount of time that
I spend with the actual writing and it's got to
be consistent it's like an athlete when you're
training you know it's you've got to be you've
got you've got to be a bit rigorous and say you
know what what do I need if I'm going to succeed
you know if my manuscript or my screenplay is not
going to chew off its own head in their drawer
while it gathers dust what do I need I need
a team I need to know people I need people to
collaborate with and I need people to you know
who are but before I need them I want to have
the relationship with the people that eventually
I'm going to need when I have a new project ready
who are those people and then make it a point
to build out your I mean there's nothing more
important than just I I don't really love the
word networking but that's what it is it's saying
I need I need my village I need my tribe I need
my team whatever that looks like and I'm not
talking just about a representative I mean a real
community of people that are my my creative collab
so twitter going on twitter being a part of writer
organizations whether they're on social media or
separate from social media absolutely where
do I get immerse myself in that conversation
so that I can get feedback so that I can find
resources I can share resources and opportunities
and if I want to introduce someone to someone
else it'll be a generosity that's well received
and reciprocated yeah put yourself in that
flow when you're not in your writing space
I think it's and and not just and not just
with other writers I think it's important
that you color outside the lines and that you be
a little bit imaginative and daring not just with
your writing but in your choice of you know
we've talked about this before most writers
think in terms of agents or producers either
representation or who's going to get my help
get my project produced and that's all wonderful
but there are all these other people out there
that people aren't knocking on their door and
they're available and they'd love to talk to you
and share their wisdom so why aren't we reaching
out to the line producer the casting director
the cinematographer etc etc are editors and other
writers that you can glean inordinate wisdom from
and have real fun with so I think that you
know it doesn't always have to be specific
you know like a specific result or goal
that you want to achieve it's just saying
my greatest currency is really being a
part of this community that is the filament
and tv enterprise right I need to walk the
streets of my community and know my neighbors
and be able to talk to them
and be welcoming of them
and what if you're shy and
maybe they're not welcoming of
you I don't believe for a moment
that they're not welcoming
I do believe that a lot of people are shy and but
that's you know being shy is not an excuse not to
succeed it's just not it's hard but I've
had I can't tell you the number of people
that I've coached over time who come back
and go oh my god I had no idea this is like
you know the red sea parting I didn't know
it was so easy and so much fun to meet people
I thought it was scary I thought there was
a monster in the closet I thought these
were fire-breathing weapon-wielding terrible
terrible people who didn't want to know me
and and it's like oh my god I just forced myself
and it was very uncomfortable it was extremely
awkward I didn't like it but I forced myself
to do for one week what you suggested and I
make two calls a day for a week and by that
friday it was like oh my gosh there was one
person who was too busy there was one person who
had some attitude but eight people welcomed me
and I'm gonna be speaking with most all of them
again in another week just the way you taught
and it's it's it's I'm not taking credit for it
it's just like it's it was just like a push go
jump in the water you're not gonna
drown flop your arms you're gonna swim
may not look beautiful the first time but it it
doesn't take long before it's like oh you let your
shoulders down and say you know what I can let
go I can lay down the stories that don't serve me
and a lot of people have that story that
oh I'm sure is there two sides of the
coin was I'm too shy I'm introverted I'm not
comfortable it's scary I don't want to do it
and the other side is they don't want me to do
it they're not friendly they're not welcoming
I have or I have no value and nothing
to contribute to the conversation
like I'm subhuman and those stories
are just stories they're not real
but we only learn by doing
that may be an exaggeration but I really believe
that doing is the way we learn fastest and if you
pick up the phone and force you to do something
that's really not native to you that's really
actually quite audacious and you do it a few
times it's suddenly it's like public speaking
everyone says publix more people fear public
speaking than death were you afraid of
your ted talk I was always horrified of
public speaking I actually enjoy it now
the things that you worry about
no one else is worried about it's crazy
because we think we are the universe but no
people are rooting for you we see that all the
time in performances whether it's public speaking
or you know singing or whatever it might be
athletes you name it we want people to win
if you just lay those stories down
long enough to take some action
you grow a new muscle very quickly
it's not terrifying it's actually
appreciated and it's the fastest path to
from a to b Gary you're a former attorney
turned Hollywood producer criminal
defense attorney correct correct okay
I'm sure you've seen some good sides of people and
maybe some not so good signs from what you've seen
how true is it that screenplays are stolen that
ideas are stolen or ideas really can't be stolen
well I wouldn't go so far to say this
cannot be stolen but in my experience
it's extraordinarily rare I see a lot of writers
very concerned about it and my my advice to them
is by all means protect your work your ip
needs to be protected you've worked hard
so at a minimum you want to put a copyright
notice on it but you also want to register it
for copyright which are different right and for
extra an extra layer of frosting on the cake you
might want to register it with the writer's guild
of america after that I wouldn't worry about it
i've I personally never the kinds of
things that I'm concerned about are not
theft of intellectual property so much as unfair
dealings right it's a totally different beast
but but actual theft of whether it's an
idea or a an existing screen player teleplay
I've never personally actually had that experience
I've been in the business a lot of years
I know it happens only because I
read about it once a decade in the in
in a trade paper that so-and-so claims x happened
but I wouldn't be concerned about it my attitude
was always when I was managing a young writer
I want the world to read this so I'm willing I'll
make a million copies I'll hire a helicopter and
drop it out over the city of la and let
everybody read this beautiful script
because I don't believe they're going to steal it
so I think there's a difference between
protecting your work and worrying about it and um
you know on on the only thing I
would add on the flip side of that is
don't be too casual about where you
invest your time and thus your where you
how you disseminate your script so while I was
joking about the helicopter I'm joking it's
you know you really want to choose wisely how you
use your time who you invest your time in meeting
and if you do that well then the other
becomes sort of a non-item you know if you're
if you're careful about who you are building as
your you know your professional infrastructure
then I wouldn't give a second thought to it I
think it's it's very hard to steal and get away
with stealing intellectual property it's
a very close-knit business and if it were
to happen there are protections but you can't
stop it so why worry about something you can't
stop well from reading the comments of some of
our videos you know people have taken a lot of
detail and and just time to recount their stories
or a story of a friend of theirs where a lot of
it sounds very similar where they go into pitch
somewhere and then a very similar idea comes out
usually with names changed but sometimes
people said that stuff hadn't really been
totally changed so I tend to think most of those
stories were true but I have no way to personally
verify that I'm sure that is actually more
common than the theft of existing scripts i
i also think people need to realize that ideas
I don't know that ideas were ever all that
tremendously valuable but in today's world less so
and I would suggest I would advise people not to
be so excited about their idea that they're busy
pitching as an idea all the time to everyone
they encounter it's actually a bad practice if
you have an idea that's that's so exciting
to you then put on the brakes and write it
and then you can protect it but ideas
that you know if you're constantly
saying oh I have this wonderful
idea let me tell you about my idea
don't be surprised if somehow some version
of that seeps into someone's consciousness
intentionally with with malice or not and
finds a life somewhere else you've invited that
you know I think you have your inner circle that
you know and you trust and you can bounce ideas
with them that's fine that's different
but I'm talking about people who are
I got an email from someone
two days ago who had been at a meeting with these
two gals in malibu this young guy was at a meeting
with these two gals and he pitched them this idea
he's written he's never written a screenplay but
he's written a couple of books apparently I don't
know the details and they said oh well maybe Gary
and I get an email saying I have
this wonderful idea you know
and I wrote him back and I said I
really am not sure what you're asking me
from what you're saying it sounds like there is
no script and he wrote back he said no it's but
I thought maybe if I wrote a treatment you read I
was like oh my gosh you know I really would would
encourage you you're a natural writer apparently
you've published books write the screenplay
because this idea of disseminating ideas and
and and treatments no one can grab hold of
that there's no real concrete outcome of great
value that you might anticipate coming from that
so why do it so don't worry about pitching
ideas if you really feel so connected to
something actually spend time with the screenplay
get it registered get it copyrighted and then go
from there don't ask for permission and tiptoe
around don't wait for the universe to bless you
unless there's a specific outcome where it makes
sense and that happens all the time I might want
to pitch an idea in the confines of you know a
close relationship that I might have with let's
say another producer or with a writer so here's
the I want to develop you know here's an idea
does this excite you is this something
you'd be interested in working on with me
that's one context and it makes perfect sense
because it has to be birthed we all birth stories
out of thin air there's nothing and then there's
a story and then there's a screenplay so along
that trajectory there are times when we want to
find people that we want to draw into the process
but to pitch it just to let people know
that we're excited about something and
we're working on something you know again if
it's if it's someone you know and trusts fine but
I wouldn't make a habit of pitching ideas and
I won't even use the word pitch because that
presumes something it's a you know term of art but
I wouldn't necessarily be sharing hither and yan
an idea that you really do are serious you have
serious intention that you're gonna actually craft
that into a project and do a screenplay or tell
a play I would I would be a little bit i'd I at
least at a minimum you should create a treatment
and copyright it and you know if you want to
batten down the hatches and be pitching the idea
that's okay but really document it protect it and
now you have a basis for a claim should that rare
occurrence happen which is that someone actually
steals your idea Gary you mentioned you
were more worried about unfair dealings
what does that mean well not everybody's
well behaved hollywood's no exception I
you know so there are we all say we have war
stories right and and certainly there have been
I'll give you an example I will try not to dance
around it so it's there are many versions of it
here's one version one version is an agent
calls me and says I have a hip pocket client
would you meet with her absolutely I'm
delighted to meet with her I asked for a little
bio biographical material maybe anything she's
written whether it's a screenplay or not just so I
welcome her she comes for a meeting and she's
absolutely fascinating really funny and bright
it's hysterical her family is remarkable and she I
won't get into because maybe it's identifiable but
anyway there's something very unique going on it's
but the family is eccentric and brilliant and so
she she's just I always ask a lot of questions so
she's filling me in on this whole family history
and her personal journey after college and this
and that the other thing and I said this is
all great okay great so an hour into it I said
would you mind terribly if I pitch you a story
and she's like okay and all I did was
I took everything she just told me
which she would never have conceived
of as a story worthy of the big screen
and I pitched her a comedy because it was
like an intelligent comedy like brilliant
and I pitched it back to her as a feature idea
and you could see her eyes getting saucer wide
very excited like oh my god that's my family's
story that's me and she said I love it I said
okay so here's the thing you said you're going
back home for a visit so I would love to ask
not as a homework assignment but just you know if
you would gather up the local newspaper publisher
gather up a bunch of the editorials copies of the
paper bring back your yearbooks from school bring
back these abcdefg and let's dig into this this
could be a lot of fun and she was all excited
like this is amazing yes I want to do this this is
great I said thank you for coming by she I said do
call me you know just be in touch when you're back
she said I'll be gone three weeks so four weeks go
by five weeks go by and I think you know I'm going
to call her agent and I called her agent I said um
you know so and so was so lovely and we I
know we talked about it and it was such a
great meeting and she was going to be gone three
weeks and she said she'd be in touch when she got
back and I haven't heard from I just want to make
sure is everything okay and the agent said well I
have good news and bad news so the good news is
that the project that you discussed with her is
now set up and I said let me guess that the
bad news I'm not involved and she said yeah
and she gave me a reason the reason
in that instance was well I took it to
a senior vice president and she has some people
with deals and she needed to feed a project to
one of their people that are under contract and us
no that's lovely of you to try and find a reason
to make me feel better but it doesn't because I
know the only reason I'm not involved is because
you didn't want me involved had you said there
was a producer on it it never would have occurred
to an executive to think otherwise so there look
these things happen and over the course of several
decades you're going to have a multiple
of these stories lost opportunities uh
people who be but just exercise poor
judgment omit information amid information
act what they think may be in their self-interest
that may or may not be true you know I've
set up projects in studios on a handshake with
the under verbal understanding with an agent
different from the story I just told that they
wouldn't close the you know they wouldn't paper
the underlying rights to the script on behalf of
their writer client until my producing deal was
at least codified as an email informally right and
I've had that violated now you think to yourself
how would a person do that because they were
going to get a commission on my fee right
a single project commission well it makes
no sense that they would chop my knees off
because it's going to cut my fee in half
but they do it and I'm not it's like I
still got a movie made I've still made a
great fee right was I happy about it no
but
you know you can't here's the thing I trust people
and I would much rather go through life like very
very occasionally being disappointed rather
than going through life mistrusting people
and saying you got a sign you know everything
has to be buttoned down I expect you're going
to behave badly no because the truth is that I
can tell you stories but they're they're they're
they're a needle in the haystack of my experience
over the course of my years in the business most
people behave reasonably well and it's on us I
do think it's incumbent on us to be really clear
and state aloud what we care about and what we
expect and if we're uncomfortable then just do
a one-page memo I mean there is a lesson I'm
too trusting I know that but there's a way not
to have that be your experience on a consistent
basis it's you know if you stay in any business
long enough you're gonna have a couple of
disappointments but they're not life-altering
one hopes Gary why do you say talent comes second
to marketing for anyone trying to make it in
Hollywood we can never underestimate talent craft
is everything but it's not everything meaning
fundamentally Hollywood is is is is not
a meritocracy it's not always the best
talent that rises to the top it's not the best
projects to get financed and and produced and
bought it's it's often based on who has the best
relationships so while it's really important and
I trust that most creatives who really want
to make it in the business are steadfast
they're committed they're studying they're writing
multiple scripts they're they're always improving
it's a it's a process it's a learning so you're
always getting better at your craft and I and I
don't underestimate the value of that so talent's
important but talent that is not connected up with
some form of effective marketing idea an action
plan some kind of a road map to make sure that you
and your body of work get noticed it can't live
in isolation talent has to be have a have a
platform it has to be announced to the world and
marketed and I think that too many writers um
tend to ignore them the the business
side the marketing side in favor of
being very committed to their writing and and
hoping to get an agent being in other words
being passive in the face of what in any other
industry would be considered perhaps unrealistic
so I think talent is not to be underestimated
it's it's it's it's it's why we're all here
but the talent needs it needs a companion
energy so that you are not a best kept secret
does that have to do with biz dev versus the
sales mindset does that have anything yeah I mean
certainly I think in a way it does the so that
you know this the sales person is is someone
who's working against quota and within a given
time horizon in there and they're looking for a
specific result which is sale they're their whole
approach is geared toward getting getting the sale
the bus the biz dev person has a totally different
job definition a different there's a different
prism or lens that they're looking through they're
looking it's like the difference almost between in
the old version agency and management one was
like income driven commission driven and the
other was commission german but it was really
about developing the talent longer term mindset
in business the biz dev people people with that
responsibility set are really looking at how do
I nurture and develop the future business and
that's not about making sales today that's about
getting to know their business about getting
to know their customer about getting to know
their needs their wants and how we can develop
a mutually beneficial relationship it's being
fundamentally other focused it's not about
what I need today it's about how can I help you
now and into the future let's let's let's create
that pathway so that I lock in a sense of loyalty
and a deeper understanding and then we can build
together so there's an inv it's it's investment
minded as opposed to sales minded and I've used
that analogy for yeah certainly for creatives
like you know be curious be a business development
person build relationships build toward a future
without the urgency without the anxiety there's
no stress in that there's no need in that
now it's just a gift of genuine curiosity about
the other and not keeping yourself a secret share
who you are and what you do and why you do it why
you care what what was the first moment when you
knew you you had to have a create you know go
down this path and be a creative professional
christie dryling yes yes christie's a dear friend
yeah and I found her book accidentally somehow and
it was really fascinating to read especially
about her upbringing and she talked about a
poverty mindset and I'm curious how we can all
fall into that trap and maybe not even realize it
yeah well I think it's very common
look I think that we're unfortunately
I won't say mis-educated i'd say
under-educated I think there are
you know in our system in our culture
there are a lot of what I consider really
essentials that we're simply not they're not in
our curriculum that we're not taught we're not
taught financial literacy we're not taught
mindset we're not taught success principles
it it it hasn't yet found its way into the
body politic that is our educational system
and I think that a lot of people do fall into
a poverty mindset they're you know it's we are
we are fed a steady diet through the internet
through the classic traditional media
what have you of of sensational
stories because that's what sells
and it's often fear-based and fear is powerful
medicine and most people are not immune to it
there's very few people who can see over
that hedgerow and stay centered and stay
present and stay committed to their vision and
their and and what what's theirs to do and we
see that you know covid we see it you know like
there's a uniform response amongst most people
to bad news and we see it all the time and I think
it sort of degrades our sense of manifest destiny
and our vigor and our determination of and belief
in what's possible applying the poverty mindset
to being active pitching working on projects
not giving up because that poverty mindset can
permeate into other areas it's not just financial
poverty it's also sort of lack of opportunity the
belief that you can't actually make something
happen doesn't have to actually mean monetary
value right so how do we how do we get ourselves
out of that because some people could come from
some you know a stable middle class environment
or upper middle class they could probably still
possess that poverty mindset being told maybe
you can't make a career out of this find a
find a stable position where you know there's
a pension very few jobs still have pensions but
people often turn away from what's possible
or from actual career choices because they
don't know how how am I going to make that a
reality and my understanding of life is it's
really not that important to understand how what's
really important is to understand what you want
be really clear about what you want
and very clear about why you want it
and at that point the how is you know
like a collaborative effort between you
the universe and seeking out the people who know
the how they've been down that path and finding
your mentors and finding your collaborators
finding your partners whatever it might be
but it's if you can't go in with that clarity
that story that's really true and clear and
persuasive about it mostly to yourself if you
believe it others will believe it right that's
that's really persuasive about what
it is that you want why you want it
and what you're willing to do for it that you're
committed to it the how just becomes the gap
that needs to be filled in with information
in relationships and that's all available
it's the determination I think a lot of people
get get stopped before they get in the game
because they don't think it's possible they think
it's too hard they don't know how they have all
these ideas because it's easy not to believe in
yourself it's easy to stay in your comfort zone
it's another way of saying it it's it takes a
certain amount of courage to step out and do
the thing that you fear others may judge you for
and by the way that you may fail at right so it's
easier to be safe and stay in your comfort zone
and not take that risk but the but it's really not
because we only have one life and regret is a
terrible terrible thing questioning yourself is
a terrible not believing in yourself is not being
willing to take risk and bet on yourself first
it's like chopping off an arm you know it's just
not a good way to treat yourself and and if you
surround yourself with no matter what your
background and I granted it's not an equal
playing field I think all souls are created
equal people are not people's backgrounds and
experiences are so so so different and but I
think we do have we see so many examples of it
that kind of courage that makes people rise
above a circumstance say I'm so committed to this
and no matter what my experience or what my
background I am going to find the people who are
more successful who are in the direction I want
to move in and I'm going to go there I'm going to
make them my target and my compatriots and what
have you my mentors I think it just you know most
people aren't natural born leaders and they don't
necessarily I read a book years and years ago
called the slight edge jeff holston I think is
the author and in that book there was really it's
he talks about habits but the thing that makes it
come to mind is there's a moment in the book when
he talks about a sociological study that was done
that determined that by the age of five which I
is what first grade that by the age of five
a child has on average heard the word no
forty thousand times and he's hurt that same
child heard the word yes eight thousand times
so literally five times the gravity holding that
belief system that human being down as there is a
yes energy uplifting or elevating or thinking
oh these things are more possible for me and
that really stuck obviously it stayed with me
I read that book years and years ago because I
thought my god the math of that is really a heavy
weight so I think the one of the keys is surren
really take yourself out of your the other comfort
zone is don't necessarily settle for those who are
your current tribe or community or the people you
hang with right like really make a decision that
you're gonna get with people who are the doers not
the dreamers with the people who will believe in
you not the ones who will judge you like really
consciously say I deserve better and I don't want
to say it's like fake until you make it because I
actually think everyone deserves it but if you're
willing to go after what you think you can grow
into what you deserve increase your capacity find
the people who are going to say yeah we support
you we not only don't judge you we encourage you
what does a successful screenwriting career look
like well everyone's going to find it differently
because everyone's needs are different everyone's
psychology is different but what I would say is
anyone who can survive by focusing the majority
of their energy on getting better at and deeper
anchors inside the film and tv business that's
success how much you earn is is you know your what
you need to earn to be successful and for example
is it successful for someone to be hard at work
as a writer while doing a day job at a an agency
or at a production company or at a studio or the
like I think yes because they're making all those
relationships I mean that's so important like if
someone's going to have to have a day job to help
support the writing or supplement what they're
earning on the writing side do it by working
in the business and make relationships because
that's the piece that otherwise is generally
missing like to me that's a successful model
but in terms of earning yeah you know some people
they're thrilled if they can make 25 000 a year
some people are only going to be happy
if they're making 100 000 or more a year
it's hard to say but you want to get yourself you
want you want to earn for your you want to option
projects you want to sell projects you want to
get hired to do a rewrite an adaptation whatever
those things might be and I think that's
you know partly what you should be you know
focused on when you're spending a lot of your time
focusing on creating the scripts your spec work
but you need to be out there shaking those
trees that's what the relationships bring
you that's the kind of opportunity that comes
in the door if you are activist whether it's
through a job or just reach you know being
determined to expand your network so it's it's
writing it's doing one job but also keeping in my
mind I'm going to be looking for other jobs at the
same time because I know this one is going to pay
me soon and then I'm gonna be out of a job again
it's it's that kind of mindset it's
like yeah I mean we're all freelancers
or many of us creatives are freelancers and you
have to have that mindset that oh I need if it's
not the most predictable income then I have to be
very activist about inviting more opportunity in
and you know I think it's a game of numbers it's a
game of inches like the more people that know and
that you articulate you've got to speak it into
the world so you've got to tell a lot of people
right to get a job you've got to tell a
bunch of people this is what I'm looking for
I'm looking for adaptations I'm looking to do
rewrites I'm looking for it while of course
I'm writing my specs and I want to option them I
want to sell them when I get them financed I want
to get them produced but over here this is the
kind of work that I'm looking for if you hear of
anything introduce me mention me right it's going
to take some time you build that up but you build
a number and enough people talking about you aware
of you who've read your work and think well of you
I mean I can give you plenty of examples and
there's a writing team that that you know one was
one was formerly is a producer but very gifted put
her together with another writer that I've worked
with in the past and all through covet they've
been hired like I think they're on their fourth
project I'm only one of the four but I hired
them on on a project and got private financing to
get them wj minimum so it's it's finding a
support system it's really putting out into
the water you have to talk about it you have
to you know it's not going to happen on its own
so yeah you're you've got to be you've got
to be your own best advocate you got to just
tell the world and everybody you me and
not not blather it at Starbucks I'm not
talking about that I'm talking about again
being a little bit more focused than that
well I guess you could do that but yeah you can
you never know you can hold up a signage Starbucks
best piece of advice you've ever
received simple question I realize it but
I mean it's profound but it's not profound we
talked earlier you know in my in in my past
in San Francisco I was a criminal defense lawyer
and it was an absolutely brilliant experience
the people that I met the things I was exposed
to the community that I served it you know if
if I've often said if our if our life is a book
that was one of the best chapters I'll ever know
it wasn't necessarily my calling in the sense
that it was a perfect fit for my temperament
I didn't want to do it into well into my adulthood
but I'm so grateful for it it taught me a lot
when that came to a close and I knew the
day it came to a close it was I was done
I was very nervous because the person I most
admire my hero my best friend was my dad and
I had to go now tell my dad not just that I was
quitting a job but that I was quitting a career
because I really didn't want to be an attorney
beyond that choice that I had made so I went
to my dad and we I pulled him out of his
business and we got to go have a bite or
something a drink and and we sat down
at this place and I was so nervous
what was his reaction going to be and finally
I said dad you know we're here because
there's something really important I want to share
with you he said what is it I said well you know
I'm gonna I'm i'm quitting my
job and I'm quitting the law it's
not what I want to do and literally in that
moment my father without missing a beat smiled
something was already wrong he smiled
and he looked at me he said that's great
and I was just like stunned it was like I
expect parental lecture number what have you
about the investment of time and money
and this is respectable and all those
typical things and I and I said dad
I just that's not what I expected
and I actually asked him why why
do you say that why is it great
and he said because I don't think he'd been happy
and I think you should go find what excites you
and whatever that is I think that's what you
should go do it was like the the utter simplicity
and heart and humanity of that moment as simple
as that statement was I was just cowed it like
took me to my knees it was like oh my god I know
that you're wise I know that you're an amazing dad
but you've just upped the game and
that's what I would say to people
and the other is a quote which I'm going to read
because I don't want to get it wrong it's from I
mean after all you don't want to misquote William
Faulkner of all people so William Faulkner had
this wonderful quote that I've always loved always
dream and shoot higher than you know you can do
don't bother just to be better than
your contemporaries or your predecessors
try to be better than yourself
that's the game you know
it's that like 100-day thing
every day I'm going to wake up I just want
to be 1 better than the me that was yesterday
were you working for a firm I was
working as a lawyer it was a foundation
in in what was the ghetto of San Francisco it was
called baby hunters point so there was the baby
hunters point foundation that about 125 people
in the center was the sort of linchpin the sexy
sort of fundraising piece which was criminal
defense so we represented the indigent adults
of that geography in lieu of the public defender
they were ours and then we had alongside that
we had the the social workers and we had the
drug rehabilitation program and we had the job
skills retraining program and we had all of these
the investigators we had the idea was a holistic
solution for this beautiful community
that was very beleaguered in many ways
keep the families together the kids
in school the guys out of jail etc and
our chief counsel was named Richard Bancroft
i was so intimidated by this man when
we first met baso profundo voice tall
good-looking African-American older
a civil rights leader in the south
before LBJ [Lyndon B. Johnson]
coined the phrase civil rights
he'd been a president a national president of the
naacp he'd seen life that I couldn't even imagine
and he was our chief counsel and then we had a
few attorneys and then a couple of schlubs like me
but then we had all these other services these
human services to serve this beautiful community
and for a kid who really had never
spent time in the projects or
in the criminal justice system certainly it was
eye-opening and it was a perfect it was a perfect
it was a perfect dance it was a
perfect marriage for me at that time
these people became my family they became my
teachers I learned more in my very first year
of interning for them than I learned in three
years of law school it was extraordinary yeah
they're still there did you see pursuit of
happiness because that takes place in San
Francisco correct yeah yeah yeah yeah great
film great story excellent yeah extraordinary
real story yeah yeah it was it was you know as
they said the best of times the worst of times I
loved I loved I loved every day that I spent there
and emotionally I was a wreck almost every night
yeah that's I wasn't I wasn't
built for criminal defense
I couldn't separate you know
I wasn't a great chess player
i wore it on my sleeve a little bit sure yeah
but again it gives you just insane levels of
appreciation for how diverse this life experience
can be and just the unexpected challenges and
joys you know like that was one of the most joyful
communities I've ever experienced in my life
do you ever go back I'm sure has it been
gentrified by now maybe yes and no not really
I mean it's it's it's such a physically it's
it's it's literally across the bridge to get
to it you don't go there unless you mean to
go there so when when I say it's segregated
I mean it like literally physically is its
own distinct area out by the old shipyards
but the truth is I could be wrong because you know
precious as land is let alone in San Francisco
maybe it's been gentrified I haven't been up
you know harlem's been gentrified maybe maybe
a hundred point been gentrified I haven't been up
to see it in oh god I don't know 15 years or more
yeah so you had the lunch with your dad
he gave you his blessing so to speak
even though you already had this plan
and then you gave your notice or you had
already given your notice at that time
I had let people know it wasn't like
I walked in gave my notice and walked
out the door these were family it was
really heart-wrenching for me to leave
but yeah I couldn't not and there were some
personal things that went on that that just
made it impossible for me to be doing that work
but it was like yeah you know when I went to law
school I went to golden gate university law school
which was actually directly across the street from
my dad's place of business and everybody knew my
dad and it was like it was just so perfect anyway
my first year of law school I met
a gal who was in my class she was
probably about my age back then single
mom two boys MSW degree and a private
social work practice that was hers oh wow and
she was a full-time first year law student
rosario her name was Rosario African-American big
personality smart as a whip and I remember being
at first like you know I didn't approach her
because she was like superwoman right how do
you have an MSW [Master’s in Social Work] and
two kids and be a full-time law student and just
how is that possible well we did become friends
and one day she approached me halfway through our
first year I think it was and she said Gary you
you know I know you've I hear you've worked out
at baby hunter's point and you know you're
close to the to them i'd love to meet them
can I go out there with you sometime and I said
of course absolutely so I check her out on every
Tuesday with staff meeting day when everybody's
there and I said let's go out on a Tuesday y'all
you'll meet everybody so I took her out introduced
her walked in introduced everybody schmoozed away
you know got into the staff meeting came out
schmoozed with everybody hung out made sure she
met everybody who was there and said I loved being
there I wasn't in a hurry to leave anyway finally
it's time to go we got my little Karmann Ghia
Volkswagen to head back to downtown San Francisco
and drop her off late afternoon so suffice to say
Rosario was not a shy retiring wallflower she was
she was full of life we get in my car and I start
driving and I've been driving now for several
minutes and she hasn't uttered a syllable we
come to a red light and I stop and I look at her
she's looking straight ahead and I said Rosario
is everything okay you haven't said a word
and privately I never experienced that right and
she turned and she looked at me and very slowly
she said those people really love you
and it took me a minute for
the dimension of that to sink in right
it was it was I think she was a bit surprised
by the dimension of our relationship
and I say I tell you that I share that anecdote
really to describe how meaningful that was
to me and how hard it was to leave them it
wasn't hard to leave the practice of law
at all but it was hard to leave the people
but I will say this just much like being a
kid in the 60s in San Francisco and being at
uc berkeley in the heyday and putting on the kind
you know and then that experience of baby hunters
those are all related in the you know in
the daisy chain of my life those are all
pivotal moments that really have everything to
do with forming my world view how I see things
what I care about it was a extraordinary
time I was very I'm still to this day
grateful that I have the history that
I have yeah pretty cool pretty blessed
and here we are in hollywood
not bad
excited for
i don't know I think I think
we're at a really exciting moment
like that for me when the studios became purchased
and you know but then he bought universal and
Sony block Columbia et cetera et cetera et
cetera and they became populated with a different
group of people and the budgets went up in
the 20 million star and all those things
align with the demise of the indies so there's
I don't know 25 or more robust companies that
were putting out as many films just if not
more than the studios collectively right
who were either broken up with their library value
or just went bankrupt or whatever happened right
so the hemdales and and and the vestrons
and all of those wonderful companies and
suddenly there was no independent cinema the
studios became more corporate they made half
as many phones with double the size budgets and
there was this contraction moment and it was it's
a time when I started to take walkabouts and do
other things alongside this thing called producing
and suddenly in because of what's
happened in recent years we now have
something that is so much more robust than that
ever was the demand for story is the the the size
of the appetite and the number of series and films
that are that are needed and being and actually
being you know be covered aside that obviously
production's been quashed for the year but but
the number of projects that are being developed
and produced overall for all of these streamers
who have a lot of diverse appetites to feed it's
absolutely stunning to me and I think it's a great
time to refocus our energies and you know be in
the game and figure out this this new landscape.